good evening we're at another critical
moment
in our fight against coronavirus i know
how difficult another lockdown will be
for families across britain for millions
who've had to juggle
child care with working from home for
young people
pulled out of the classroom for
businesses
that have been asked to close and for
our amazing key workers who
stepped up throughout this pandemic
asked to put their country first
once again and i know that after so much
sacrifice and suffering you're
frustrated that we're back here again
angry at the mistakes the government has
made
and worried about the future
there are serious questions for the
government to answer
why did they not act sooner
why after 22 billion pounds of taxpayers
money
is the testing system still not working
why were families given so little time
to plan for
child care and for schools closing
and why once again have businesses and
millions of working people
not being given the support that they
need
we'll keep asking these questions and
fighting for proper support
for businesses and for families
but whatever our quarrels with the
government and with the prime minister
the country now needs us to come
together
the virus is out of control
infections are rising sharply more
people are in hospital
and tragically more people are losing
their loved ones
at this darkest of moments we need a new
national effort
to rekindle the spirit of last march to
come together
and to do everything possible to stay at
home
to protect the nhs and save lives
so labor will support this lockdown
we will vote for it in parliament we
will join in this national effort
challenging the government where it's
getting it wrong
standing up for families and businesses
and urging everyone
to follow the new guidance
the british people have sacrificed so
much
but thanks to the dedication and
brilliance of our scientists
there is hope of a way out of this
nightmare
let's recapture the spirit we saw at the
start of the pandemic
we now need the government to deliver
for the british people
we now need a government that's worthy
of the british people
and that means using this lockdown to
establish a
massive immediate and round-the-clock
vaccination program
to deliver millions of doses a week by
the end of this month
in every village every town every high
street
and every gp surgery we need our
businesses and public services
working hand in hand for the common good
we need an army of volunteers and to use
every resource
at our disposal this is now a race
between the virus and the vaccine and if
we pull together as a nation
we could win i pledge to do everything i
can
to help in this national mission
we were the first country in the world
to get the vaccine
let's be the first in the world to get
our country vaccinated
we need a new contract between the
government and the british people
the country stays at home the government
delivers the vaccine
i want to finish by talking directly to
everyone who
feels worn down and exhausted by the
current situation
i know the next few weeks will be really
hard
for families who long to be together
again
but we will get through this because of
our scientists
the dedication of our key workers and
the strength of the british people
we will recover we'll rebuild
we'll see each other again and then we
can forge the better future
i know is possible thank you